they speak to a nation where too often
just the color of your skin put your
life at risk they speak to a nation
where more than 100,000 people have lost
their lives the virus and 40 million and
file for unemployment but the
disproportionate number of those deaths
and job losses concentrated in black and
brown communities and they speak to a
nation where every day millions of
people and millions not at the moment of
losing their life but in the course of
living their life are saying to
themselves I can't breathe it's a
wake-up call to our nation in my view
it's for all of us and I mean all of us
it's not the first time we've heard
those words they're the same words we
heard from Eric garner when his life was
taken away six years ago but it's time
to listen to those words to try to
understand them to respond to them
respond with action a country is crying
out for leadership leadership the q9s
leadership that brings us together
leadership that can recognize pain and
deep grief of communities that have had
a knee on their neck for a long time
there's no place for violence no place
for looting or destroying property or
burning churches or destroying
businesses many of them built by the
very people of color for the first time
and their lives are beginning to realize
their dreams and build wealth for their
families nor is it acceptable for our
police sworn to protect and serve all
people to escalate tension resort to
excessive violence we need to
distinguish between legitimate peaceful
protests and opportunities to violent
destruction we have to be vigilant about
the violence that's being done by this
incumbent president to our economy and
to the pursuit of justice when peaceful
protesters dispersed in order for a
president a president from the doorstep
of the people's house the White House
using tear gas
and flash grenades in order to stage a
photo op a photo op and one of the most
historic churches in the country or at
least in Washington DC we can be
forgiven for believing the president's
more interested in in power than in
principle were just serving the passions
of his base than the needs of the people
in his care for that's what the
presidency is the duty to care to care
for all of us not just those who vote
for us but all of us not just our donors
but all of us the president held up the
Bible at Saint John's Church yesterday I
just wish he opened it once in a while
instead of brandishing it if he opened
it he could have learned something
they're all called to love one another
as we love ourselves it's really hard
work but it's the work of America Donald
Trump is interested in doing that work
instead he's preening and sweeping away
all the guardrails that law protected
our democracy guardrails that have
helped make possible this nation's path
to a more perfect union a union that
constantly requires reform and
rededication and yes the protest from
voices that are mistreated ignored left
out or left behind but it is a union be
worth fighting for and that's why I'm
running for president in editions of the
Bible the president might also want to
open the US Constitution listen well if
he did he'd find a thing called the
First Amendment and what it says and
began it says the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
their government for redress of
grievances that's kind of an essential
notion building into this country mr.
president that's America
that's America no horses rising up on
their hind legs to push back peaceful
protests not using the American military
to move against the American people this
is a nation of values our freedom to
speak is a cherished knowledge that
lives inside every American almost from
the time you're a kid we're not allow
any president to quiet our voice we all
let those who see this as an opportunity
to sow chaos throw up a smoke screen to
distract us some very real religious and
legitimate grievances at the heart of
these protests we can't we can't leave
this moment I can't leave this moment
thinking that we can once again turn
away and do nothing I can't do that this
time we just can the mower has come for
our nation to deal with systemic racism
to deal with the growing economic
inequity that exists in our nation to
deal with the denial of the promise of
this nation made to so many you know
I've said from the outset of this
election that we're in the battle for
the soul of this nation and we are in
the battle for the soul of this nation
well we believe that maybe most
importantly who we want to be it's all
at stake that's truer today than it has
ever been at least in my lifetime and
it's this urgency it's in the services
we can find a path forward now the
history of this nation teaches us that
in some of our darkest moments of
despair we've made some of our greatest
progress some of our darkest moments of
13 14 15 - memos follow the Civil War
the greatest economic growth in world
history
grew out of the Great Depression Civil
Rights Act of 1964 and 65 OD Rights Act
of 65 came and the tracks of bull
Connor's vicious dogs to prior phrase
Reverend barber it's the morning we find
hope it's in the morning when we find
hope only more but it's gonna take more
than talk we've had talked before that
protests before we've gotta now vow to
make this at least an area of action and
reverse the systemic racism with a
long-overdue concrete changes the action
will not be completed but in the first
hundred days of my presidency if I'm
fortunate enough to be elected or even
of my entire term it's going to take the
work of a generation but if this agenda
will take time to complete it should not
wait for the first hundred days of my
presidency to get started a down payment
on what is long overdue should come now
should come immediately I called the
Congress to act this month on measures
that would be the first step in this
direction starting with real police
reform Congressman Jefferies has a bill
to outlaw choke holes Congress should
put it on the President's desk in the
next few days there are other measures
to stop transferring weapons of war to
police forces improve oversight and
accountability to create a model use of
force standard that also should be made
law this month no more excuses no delays
if Mitch McConnell can bring in the
United States Senate to confirm Trump's
unqualified judicial nominees who will
run roughshod over our Constitution now
it's time to pass legislation will give
true meaning to our constitutional
promise of equal protection under the
law looking ahead in the first hundred
days of my presidency I've committed to
creating a national police oversight
Commission I've long believed we need
real community policing we need each and
every Police Department of the country
stand a comprehensive review of the
Undertaker conference review of their
hiring their training through the
escalation some have already done it
some how are the process of doing it the
federal government should give give the
cities and states the tools and the
resources they need to implement reforms
more police officers meet the higher
standards of their procession most of
them do it all the more reason why bad
cops should be dealt with severely and
swiftly we all need to take a hard look
at the culture it allows for the
senseless tragedies to keep happening
and we need to learn from the cities and
the precincts that are getting it right
we know though we have in order to have
true American justice we need economic
justice as well here to is there's much
to be done as a media step Congress
should act should act now to rectify
racial inequities that allow Cova 19
recovery funds to be diverted from where
they live I'll be setting forth my
general economic justice and opportunity
in the weeks and months ahead but it
begins with health care health care
should be a right not a privilege the
quickest route to universal coverage in
this country is to expand on Obamacare
we could do it we should do it but this
president even now in the midst of a
public health crisis with massive
unemployment as well wants to destroy it
he doesn't care how many millions
Americans will be heard because he
consumed with his blinding ego when it
comes to Barack Obama President Obama
the president should withdraw his
lawsuit to strike down Obamacare and the
Congress should prepare to pass the Act
I proposed to expand Obama care to
millions more so everyone's covered
these last few months we've seen
America's true heroes health care
workers Doc's nurses delivery truck
drivers grocery store workers you know
we've come up with a new phrase for them
essential work
essential workers but we need to do more
than praise them we need to pay them we
need to pay them because they weren't
clear before it's clear now this country
wasn't built by Wall Street bankers and
CEOs and was built by the great American
middle class which is built by unions
and our essential workers you know I
know there's enormous fear and
uncertainty and anger in the country I
understand I know so many Americans are
suffering suffering loss of a loved one
suffering economic hardship wondering
can I feed my family tomorrow what's
going to happen suffer under the weight
of a generation after generation after
generation I've heard inflicted on
people of color and black brown and
Native communities in particular like
many of you I know what it means to
grieve my losses are not the same as
losses felt by so many but I know what
it feels like when you think you can't
go on I know what it means to have that
black hole in your chest where your
grief is being sucked into it just a few
days ago mark the fifth anniversary of
my son Bo's passing from cancer there's
still moments and when the pain is so
great it feels no different than the day
I sat in that bed as he passed away but
I also know but the best way to bear
loss and pain is to turn it into that
anger and anguish into purpose and
Americans know what our purpose is as a
nation that's to be guided that's to be
guided guided us from the very beginning
notice we reported the day that
President John F Kennedy was
assassinated little Yolanda King came
home from school
Lenin jumped in her daddy's arms and
said Oh daddy she said now we're never
gonna get our freedom through dad he was
reassuring strong and brave
he said no don't worry baby it's gonna
be okay it's gonna be all right
amid the violence and fear dr. King he
persevered he was driven by his dream of
a nation where justice runs down like
water and righteousness like a mighty
stream then in 1968 hate cut him down in
Memphis few days before dr. King was
murdered he gave a final Sunday sermon
to Washington where he told us that
though the arc of the moral universe is
long he said it bends towards justice
and we know we can bend it because we
have we have to believe that still
that's our purpose it's been our purpose
in the very beginning to become a nation
we're all men and women are not only
created equal but they're treated
equally not just crazy legal but treated
equally to become a nation defined in
dr. King's words not only by the absence
of tension but by the presence of
justice it's not enough just to not
attention but justice today in America
is hard to keep faith that justice is
hand I know that you know that the pain
is raw the pain is real the president
United States must be part of the
solution not the
problem but this president today is part
of the problem and accelerates it when
he tweeted the words when the looting
starts the shooting starts they weren't
the words of a president they're words
of a racist Miami police chief in the
60s when he tweeted the protesters quote
would have been greeted with the most
vicious dogs when people would have been
really hurt end of quote
they weren't the words of a president
they were the kind of words Bull Connor
would have used unleashing his dogs on
innocent women and children
you know the American story is a story
about action and reaction that's
actually works we can't be naive about
it I wish I could say that hate began
with Donald Trump and with him it didn't
and it won't American history is in a
fairy tale
with a guaranteed happy ending the
battle for the soul of this nation has
been a constant push and pull for more
than 240 years a tug of war between the
American ideal that were all created
equal in the harsh reality that racism
has long torn us apart
the honest truth is that both elements
are part the American character both
elements at our best the American ideal
wins out but it's never a rout it's
always a fight that the battle is never
fully won but we can't ignore the truth
that we're out our best when we open our
hearts rather than clench our fists
Donald Trump has turned this country
into a battlefield riven by old
resentments and fresh fears he thinks
division helps him his narcissism has
become
more important than the nation's
well-being that he leads I ask every
American I mean this in the bottom I ask
every American look at where we are now
and think anew is this who we are is
this what we want to be is this we want
to pass on to our children and our
grandchildren fear anger finger-pointing
ready I'll do my job and I will take
responsibility I won't blame others I'll
never forget I will never forget I
promise you this job is not about me
it's about you it's about us the work
not only to rebuild the nation but to
build it better than it was we're the
only nation of the world that goes
through crisis that comes out better we
to build a better future that's what
America does to build a better future we
build the future it may in fact be the
most American thing to do build the
future we hunger for Liberty the way
Harriet Tubman and Frederick Douglass
did we thirst for the vote like susan b
anthony and Ella Baker and John Lewis
did we strive to explore the store as
cure disease make an imperfect Union
more perfect than has been we make them
up short but at our best we try my
fellow Americans were facing a
formidable enemies they include not only
the coronavirus and the table impact
from the lives and livelihoods but also
the selfishness and fear that have
loomed over our national life for the
last three years I choose those words
advisedly selfishness and fear defeating
those enemies requires us to do our duty
and that Duty includes remembering who
we should be who we should be
we should be the America of FDR and
Eisenhower of Rosa Parks and Martin
Luther King jr. of Jonas Salk and Neil
Armstrong we should be the America that
cherishes life liberty and courage and
above all we should be the American that
chose to each other each and every one
of us you know we're a nation in pain
we must lot but our pain destroy us
we're a nation enraged
we can't live out our rage consume us
we're a nation that's exhausted but we
will not allow our exhaustion defeatist
as president it's my commitment to all
of you to lead on these issues and to
listen because I truly believe in my
heart of hearts we can't overcome we
stand together finally as one America
over eyes stronger than we were before
we'll move that art closer to justice
we'll reach out to one another so speak
out for one another and please please do
us recently been happening take care of
one another this is the United States of
America there's never been anything
we've been unable to do when we set our
mind to do it and we've done it together
together United that's where you are at
our best then god bless you all and may
God protect our troops